[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
sollte Robert Habeck die Hoffnung gehabt
haben dass er mit dem atompolitischen
Spagat den er gestern voll führte dass
heikle Kernkraft Thema abräumt so ist
ihm das nicht gelungen ein Großteil der
Grünen scheint sich zwar daran
festzuhalten dass alle AKWs wie geplant
erstmal vom Netz gehen sollen und
insofern das große grüne Tabu
Laufzeitverlängerung nicht gebrochen
wird und die SPD hält sich zurück wohl
in der stillen Erkenntnis dass bei dem
Thema für sie nicht sehr viel zu
gewinnen ist aber
Koalitionspartner FDP spielt nicht mit
und die Opposition trommelt sich bereits
in Stellung und wittert Winterluft
sozusagen Stefan leifert Berichte
manchmal muss man nach Bayern schauen um
die Betriebstemparatur deutscher Politik
zu fühlen Markus Söder will über die
Kabinettssitzung in München berichten
doch was folgt sind 9 Minuten Tirade auf
harbex kernkraftpläne in Berlin wir
fordern den Bund auf nachhaltig dies zu
ändern diese einzelne Entscheidung von
ein Habeck nicht zu Entscheidung der
Regierung zu machen und die Aufforderung
der Bundeskanzler Energiepolitik zur
Chefsache zu machen
das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium wirkt
an der Stelle eindeutig überfordert die
Angst vor Energieknappheit in Bayern sei
auch wegen eigener Versäumnisse der
Vergangenheit so groß räumt mancher in
der CSU umso willkommener ist jede
Angriffsfläche die Berlins Politik der
Gegenwart bietet nach dem Murks bei der
gasumlage ist die Entscheidung von
gestern Abend die Atomkraft nicht mehr
zu verlängern der nächste schwere Fehler
der grüne Vizekanzler wollte einen
Kompromiss der die Lager befriedet
heraus kam ein Vorschlag der den Streit
vergrößert wie geplant soll demnach das
AKW Emsland 2022 vom Netz gehen
Neckarwestheim und Isar 2 bis April für
den Notfall in Reserve bleiben
Kritik aus Süden und Union war
eingepreist doch die Opposition kommt
auch aus der eigenen Koalition und zwar
heftig die Entscheidung des
Wirtschaftsministers ist natürlich aus
unserer Sicht enttäuschend ich habe mir
eine andere Entscheidung gewünscht denn
diese Entscheidung ist aus meiner Sicht
nicht im Einklang mit der
energiepolitischen Realität in
Deutschland und das darf nicht der
Eindruck entstehen dass hier
parteipolitische Überlegungen eine Rolle
spielen oder eine Rolle gespielt haben
das wäre nicht gut für unser Land die
Energiekrise des Winters steht noch
bevor die Koalitionskrise ist schon da
die Grünen versuchen für die eigenen
Reihen den Spagat in Atomausstieg und
Notbetrieb keinen Widerspruch zu sehen
wir haben kein Problem mit der
Strommenge das hat der Stress das
gezeigt oder mit den Netzstabilität für
den Extremfall dass das gefährdet ist
brauchen wir diese beiden AKWs für die
über diesen Winter danach ist Schluss
Atomkraftwerke als Stromreserve is 2
Niederbayern wäre eins der beiden Ende
des Jahres soll der Betrieb runterfahren
im Notfall wieder hochfahren so der
habeck-plan expertenrätseln wie das
gehen soll hier ist es insbesondere so
dass wir ja die Anlagen eigentlich am
31.12 abgeschaltet hätten und das heißt
wir haben im Reaktorkern kaum noch
Reserven drin um die nutzen zu können
ist es sehr schwierig wieder anzufahren
und das kann im Prozess sein der
mindestens eine Woche dauert eher
wahrscheinlich mehrere Wochen sogar der
Zustand der deutschen Atomkraftwerke sei
grundsätzlich gut bescheinigen Experten
die Berliner Ampelkoalition würde diesen
Test gerade kaum bestehen
zu dem Thema gibt es nachher im heute
journal Update noch ein Interview mit
der Wirtschaftsweisen Veronika Grimm
dass sich die Lage am deutschen
Strommarkt verschärft hat liegt nicht
nur am gasproblem wie so oft kommt in
einer Krise viel zusammen ein
erheblicher Faktor ist auch das
Stromproblem das Frankreich gerade hat
und deshalb sehr viel Strom importieren
muss unter anderem aus Deutschland mehr
als die Hälfte der französischen
Atomkraftwerke können aktuell gar nicht
produzieren weitere nur eingeschränkt
für ein Land das massiv auf Atomstrom
setzt ist das ein gewaltiger Ausfall
hinzu kommt dass viele Franzosen auch
elektrisch heizen die französische
Regierung hat für den Winter sogar
geplante Blackouts angekündigt wenn es
dem Land nicht gelingt seinen
Stromverbrauch zu reduzieren Thomas
Walde über Frankreichs Energiekrise
für die die im Schwimmbad von Limo Sport
und Erholung suchen gibt es eine kalte
Dusche oder genau genommen nicht mal die
geschlossen wie 29 andere Bäder wegen
Energiekrise
ich hätte gedacht dass man vielleicht
die Wassertemperatur senkt aber
Erschließen von heute auf morgen das
hätte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht erwartet
ob er sich das so gedacht hat Präsident
macron fordert gerade seine Landsleute
eindringlich auf 10% Energie zu sparen
mit einer unterschwelligen Drohung
wenn wir uns alle gemeinsam so verhalten
dass wir zusammen Energie sparen dann
wird es auch keine Rationierung und kein
abschalten geben
bisher kam der Strom in Frankreich aus
der Steckdose 70% aus Atomkraft nun
stehen laut Energieministerium 32 von 56
Reaktoren still wegen Korrosion und
Wartungsarbeiten wie in schenau Arbeiten
Ingenieure mit Hochdruck das Ziel ist
den Reaktor schnell ans Netz zu bringen
ein Reaktor der nicht funktioniert
bringt kein Geld der Sommer verschärfte
das Problem fünf Atomkraftwerke wie das
in Gold fesch laufen nur mit
Ausnahmegenehmigung da sie wärmeres
Kühlwasser zurückleiten als erlaubt zum
Ärger von Umweltschützern
mit mehr als 30 Grad zurückgeleitet wird
kann weniger Sauerstoff aufnehmen dabei
brauchen die Fische genau wie wir
Sauerstoff
die Regierung kündigt anders alle
Atommeiler im Winter wieder regulär ans
Netz sollen bis dahin setzt Frankreich
neben dem Energiesparen auf europäische
Solidarität
einfach sagen darf deutschland braucht
von uns Gas und wir brauchen Strom aus
Europa insbesondere aus Deutschland
Frankreich sagt das ist mittels seiner
vier flüssigkeits-terminals Deutschland
beliefern könne Frankreich sei bereit
bis zum Winter eine neue Gasleitung nach
Deutschland zu bauen Gas aus Frankreich
gegen deutschen Strom
es ist unglaublich in Frankreich glaubt
man ja wer sein stark in der
Stromproduktion wegen unserer Atomkraft
die wir doch beherrschen und jetzt
müssen wir Strom aus Deutschland
importieren wir folgen einer Fiktion die
keinen Sinn macht wir müssten
bescheidener sein und dem folgen was
wirklich ist und nicht dem Bild dass wir
von uns selbst haben
die Regierung gerät unter Druck heute
versuchte sie die Franzosen zu beruhigen
Energiesparen heißt nicht weniger
Transport und Mobilität sparen heißt
nicht dass weniger Züge fahren
apropos Zug die Fußballer von Paris St
Germain gerieten heute unterdrückt
Spieler hatten ein Video aus dem
Privatjet gepostet für einen kurzen
Hüpfer nach Nord gefragt ob man dafür
nicht den Zug nehmen könne meinte der
Trainer wir haben mit den Leuten
gesprochen die für den Transport
zuständig sind ob wir nicht künftig per
stromsegler reisen können
[Musik]
fand das lustig die Regierung eher nicht
sie versteht bei allem was auch nur
entfernt mit Energie zu tun hat derzeit
keinen Spaß
tja noch mal eine ganz andere Dimension
hat aktuell die Sorge um Europas größtes
Atomkraftwerk saporicia ein Atommeiler
der zur Kriegsbeute geworden ist den
ukrainische Mitarbeiter am Laufen halten
während sie von den russischen Besatzern
bewacht werden in dessen Umfeld gekämpft
wird in dem es laut ukrainische
Regierung bereits mehrfach zu kritischen
Situationen gekommen sein soll auch
heute gab es dort wieder Beschuss
nach mühsam Verhandlungen hatte die
Internationale Atomenergiebehörde letzte
Woche eine Mission von Inspekteuren
dorthin geschickt heute hat sie ihren
Bericht vorgelegt und vor wenigen
Minuten hat ihr Leiter Raphael grossi
vor dem UN-Sicherheitsrat in New York
gesprochen
Johannes Hanau beobachtet das für uns in
New York Johannes bereits in dem
schriftlichen Bericht der heute
Nachmittag veröffentlicht wurde hatte
die eaea ja massive Sorge zum Ausdruck
gebracht was waren denn jetzt die
Kernaussagen ihres Leiters im
Sicherheitsrat
also Rafael grossy hat hier eben vor dem
Sicherheitsrat noch mal ganz klar
gemacht dass er ein großer Sorge ist das
war eine weiteren Eskalation ist zu
einem massiven Atomunfall kommen könnte
mit schweren Folgen nicht nur für die
Ukraine sondern weit über die Ukraine
hinaus und hat gesagt das ganze sein
Moment ein Spiel mit dem Feuer und er
hat seine Einschätzung relativ
detailliert hergeleitet die ihr ja hat
einen sogenannte 7-sol-modell entwickelt
das auch die Sicherheit von
Atomkraftwerken in Kriegsgebieten
garantieren soll und dazu gehört unter
anderem die physische Unversehrtheit der
Reaktoren und der abklingenbecken die
Funktionsfähigkeit der Sicherheitssystem
aber auch externe Stromversorgung oder
persönliche stressfreies Arbeiten des
Personals und hat hier noch mal gesagt
dass alle sieben Säulen eigentlich
mindestens angeknackt sind was eine
riesige Gefahr ist und hat vorgeschlagen
dass man sofort die Kampfhandlungen
einstellt dass man die Fahrzeuge
Militärfahrzeuge auf dem Gelände aus dem
Gelände hinaus bringt dass man auch
weiter versuchen soll die Kommunikation
wiederherzustellen wichtigster Punkt
aber war er hat vorgeschlagen eine
sogenannte entbilit Sicherheitszone rund
um das Atomkraftwerk herzustellen und
das ist im Moment glaube ich ziemlich
heiß umstritten auch mit den Russen und
den Ukrainern und ist auf jeden Fall ein
bemerkenswerter Vorschlag
wir merkenswert auf jeden Fall aber es
gibt natürlich auch bemerkenswert das
ist das noch nie gegeben hat sozusagen
kriegs- und Kampfhandlungen in und rund
um ein Atomkraftwerk und solche
außergewöhnlichen Situationen erfordern
außergewöhnliche Maßnahmen der
UN-Generalsekretär hat hier gerade zu
Beginn der Sitzung noch mal gesagt die
Russen sollen aus dem Atomkraftwerk
abziehen aber die Ukraine müssten die
Garantie geben dass sie mit dem Militär
nicht hineingehen denn es seien ziviles
Objekt oder soll auch zivil genutzt
werden und es wird wahrscheinlich jetzt
erhebliche Diskussionen in den nächsten
Tagen und Wochen geben wie man
möglicherweise eine solche Zone
einrichten soll der russische
Botschafter hat eben schon gesprochen
hat sich ist nicht mit einem Wort darauf
eingegangen man muss damit rechnen dass
eine solche Entscheidung auch in einem
Vito Russlands immer wieder scheitern
wird danke schön Johannes für diese
Informationen direkt aus New York
ja eine außergewöhnliche Situation
darüber wollen wir mit einem Experten
sprechen mit Sebastian stranski ist bei
der Gesellschaft für Anlagen und
Reaktorsicherheit der Leiter der
Abteilung internationale Projekte und
der ist Spezialist vor allen Dingen auch
für russische Atomanlagen guten Abend
Herr stranzing guten Abend sie haben
diesen Bericht der IAA natürlich auch
gelesen was besorgt sie da am meisten
was fällt Ihnen da sofort ins Auge der
Bericht fast das zusammen was wir seit
Monaten wissen oder auch vermuten aus
den
wissensbausteinen die wir aus der
Ukraine direkt oder indirekt bekommen
haben und ich finde diesen Bericht sehr
sehr kompakt und sehr prononciert also
diese sieben sollen Modell was er Hano
ja schon erwähnt hat ist ein neues
Modell was die ihr eher entwickelt hat
um Kernkraftwerke in Kriegsgebieten auch
beurteilen zu können oder die Sicherheit
gewährleisten zu können und
er beschreibt sehr sehr eindringlich
eindringlich die reale Situation er sagt
ja auch also der sind jetzt eben auch
noch mal Herr grossi vom Sicherheitsrat
wir spielen mit dem Feuer wir haben
Sorge für eine nuklearen Unfall wie
würde ein solcher Unfall dort aussehen
können vor welcher Gefahr hat man dort
die größte Sorge also ich denke das was
Herr grossy mit der Sorge nach dem
nuklearen Unfall sagt ist eine sehr
eindringliche Formulierung eines
möglichen Szenarios und wir haben ja
hier etwas was eine völlige Umkehrung
all der Prinzipien darstellt die es
eigentlich seit der
seit Beginn der friedlichen Nutzung der
Kernkraft gibt während es bisher
Bestreben aller Betreiber alle
Aufsichtsbehörden oder aller Beteiligten
waren die Sicherheit eines
Kernkraftwerkes möglichst groß zu machen
aus Fehlern der Vergangenheit auch aus
Unfällen zu lernen um den Schutz der der
Umgebung der Bevölkerung immer weiter zu
verbessern haben wir hier genau die das
Umgekehrte das heißt hier wird etwas
getan um die Sicherheit eines
Kernkraftwerkes herabzusetzen
und ich denke wenn er große sagt wir
haben Angst vor einem großen Unfall oder
er hat Angst vor einem großen Unfall
dann ist das sowas wie ein aufrüttelnder
Appell so nach dem Motto bitte bemerkt
was da gerade passieren könnte sollte
ich sie meinen es steht jetzt dort nicht
unmittelbar eine eine radioaktive
Verseuchung aus weil wir haben ja
gestern gehört dass offenbar der sechste
und letzte Reaktor wieder vom
ukrainischen Stromnetz genommen ist dass
das beruhigt dann erstmal wenn man das
hört man muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass
wir sehr sehr weit von einem
radioaktiven Unfall derzeit entfernt
sind und auch wenn es etwas paradox
klingt die Reaktoren befinden sich
derzeit im Normalbetrieb wir haben eine
Klassifikation über die Betriebszustände
von Kernkraftwerken und die reichen von
normalen Betrieb bis hin zu einem
Störfall und alle sechs Reaktoren
befinden sich immer noch im
Normalbetrieb 15 abgeschaltet einer ist
sogar entladen dort befinden sich die
Brennelemente im Brennelement
Lagerbecken im sogenannten Abklingbecken
und der sechste Reaktor ist im
Leistungsbetrieb mit verminderter
Leistung und versorgt kontinuierlich den
Standort und damit auch die
die Kühlung der anderen vier Reaktoren
bzw das Einbrennen mit lagerbeckens und
wenn der sechste abgeschüttet werden
muss wie er das offenbar gestern
geschehen ist um einen Brand zu löschen
der übernimmt dann diese Aufgabe das zu
kühlen also der sechste Reaktor ist
gestern nicht abgestellt worden sondern
der sechs Reaktor ist gestern in den
Inselbetrieb gegangen so sagen wir es
technisch das heißt er hat sie Leistung
soweit zurückgefahren dass er genau in
der Lage ist den Bedarf des Standortes
zu versorgen und das macht er seitdem
kontinuierlich und das macht er
hoffentlich auch noch die nächste Zeit
und selbst für den Fall gibt es noch
eine reservestromleitung von einem
Wärmekraftwerk die den Standort
versorgen könnte und über die dann auch
die nachkühlung der Reaktoren
gewährleistet wäre
es gibt ja den Verdacht dass die Russen
eigentlich Vorhaben dieses Atomkraftwerk
an hier ist russische Stromnetz ans
einzuspeisen und damit die Grenze
versorgen ist das technisch möglich
grundsätzlich ist es technisch möglich
aber sehr sehr schwierig es ist so dass
das ukrainische Netz seit dem 16 März
diesen Jahres mit dem europäischen Strom
der synchronisiert ist das heißt die
ukrainischen Kernkraftwerke können Strom
ins ukrainische Netz einspeisen das kann
über koppelstellen in die europäischen
Staaten weitergeleitet werden so zum
Beispiel über Verbindungsleitungen
zwischen Ukraine Rumänien und Ukraine
der und der Slowakei und das passiert ja
auch teilen das russische Netz hat eine
andere netzsynchronisation und man
müsste bevor man das Kraftwerk
saporischer mit dem UK mit dem
russischen Netz synchronisiert erst
einmal es vom ukrainischen Netz komplett
trennen um es dann sukzessive mit dem
russischen Netz zu synchronisieren das
ist allerdings nicht so einfach sondern
da braucht man schon mehrere Kraftwerke
und ein Netzabschnitt
immer wieder sukzessive Verbindungen
dann plötzlich gekappt werden
die drei russischen Leitungen oder ich
muss es anders sein die drei
hauptverbindungsleitungen die 700kv
Leitung die in den russisch besetzten
Teil der Ukraine in den donbas oder auf
die Krim führen sind ja schon seit
Monaten außer Betrieb die letzte
hauptverbindungsleitung die noch
funktioniert hat bis zur letzten Woche
das war die Simon des 50kv-leitung die
über die Nepper rüber nach Norden
geführt hat in das Ukrainisch
kontrollierte taritorium deine letzte
Frage wenn ein solches Kernkraftwerk
beschossen wird also sehr groß sie sagte
er habe ein Schusslöcher auch immer
wieder gesehen oder in einer Granaten
niedergehen wie gefährlich ist das ich
meine wir wissen kernkraftwerke sind
wohl offenbar für ein Flugzeugabsturz
mehr oder weniger gesichert hofft man
jedenfalls aber was ist mit Raketen und
Granaten
wenn ein krankkraftwerk und hier ganz
speziell die Reaktoren die er umhüllt
sind von einer stahlbetonhülle oder auch
die anderen Sicherheitsgebäude
beschossen würden da würde zunächst
erstmal gar nichts passieren das heißt
eine Granate könnte auf das Containment
Auftreffen ohne dass dem Containment
ohne seiner signifikanten Schädigung des
Containments käme sondern das könnt ihr
mir das dafür ausgelegt das sind
anderthalb Meter Stahlbeton und was man
auch wissen muss dass selbst wenn ein
solches Containment durch den Beschuss
beschädigt würde bedeutet das nicht
automatisch dass es zu einem
kerntechnischen Unfall oder zu einer
Kernschmelze kommt dazu würde es erst
dann kommen wenn es auf Dauer nicht mehr
gelingt die nach Wärme aus den Reaktoren
abzuführen und dafür gibt es diverse
Sicherheitssysteme an jedem Reaktor
selbst ein dreistängiges dreistelliges
ausgeführtes Sicherheitssystem und nach
Fukushima hat die Ukraine den Stresstest
der Europäischen Union freiwillig
mitgemacht und hat
nachrüstmaßnahmen getroffen zum Beispiel
mobile Notstromdiesel mobile
Einrichtungen zum Einspeisen von
Kühlwasser die weiterhin ein solches
Ereignis sicher verhindern sollen
drückt ja zumindest etwas Herr
stranzgeht danke für die Information und
das Gespräch vielen Dank
und jetzt geht es erstmal bei dir weiter
Heinz mit den Nachrichten im Bundestag
hat die haushaltswoche begonnen bis
Freitag werden die etas der einzelnen
Ministerien diskutiert die Regierung
plant Ausgaben in Höhe von
445,2 Milliarden Euro deutlich weniger
als in den vergangenen Jahren das
Finanzministerium wird erstmals seit der
Pandemie die Schuldenbremse wieder
einhalten die Opposition kritisiert die
Pläne als unrealistisch
diese Woche auch noch im Bundestag das
neue
Infektionsschutzgesetz mit den weiteren
corona-maßnahmen anders als geplant soll
die maskenpflicht in Flugzeugen und
wegfallen sie kann aber laut
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach bei
steigenden Fallzahlen per Verordnung
wieder in Kraft gesetzt werden entfernt
Zügen soll eine bundesweite
maskenpflicht bestehen bleiben für Busse
und Bahnen im Nahverkehr können es
weiter die länderregeln
in Großbritannien ist die bisherige
Außenministerin Liz Trust neue
Regierungschefin der offizielle Auftrag
kam von Königin Elisabeth der zweiten
bei einer Audienz auf Schloss Balmoral
in Schottland zurück in London kündigte
Trust unter anderem schnelle Schritte an
um den enormen Anstieg der
Lebenshaltungskosten abzufedern
Pakistan kämpft weiter gegen die Folgen
der verheerenden Überschwemmungen erste
Flüge einer Luftbrücke sind nun
unterwegs um Flutopfer zu versorgen 33
Millionen Menschen sind von der Flut
betroffen jeder fünfte benötige dringend
humanitäre Hilfe so die UNO mindestens
1300 Menschen starben in den Fluten
Überlebende sind bedroht von Krankheiten
und Hunger durch massive Regenfälle ist
ein Drittel des Landes überschwemmt und
oft ist Versorgung nur aus der Luft oder
mit Schiffen möglich
wenn sie den Menschen helfen wollen
können Sie das mit einer Spende an der
sektionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
iban.de
65-100 400
600-100-400 Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe
Pakistan
eine Freundschaft die ein Geschenk ist
die Bundespräsident Steinmeier kürzlich
sagte die Freundschaft zwischen
Deutschland und Israel die nie für
selbstverständlich genommen werden kann
und so ist es auch immer etwas
Besonderes wenn ein israelisches
Staatsoberhaupt im Bundestag Auftritt
der Besuch von Israels Präsident Herzog
hatte unter schwierigen Vorzeichen
begonnen das gemeinsame gedenken gestern
an das olympia-attentat vor 50 Jahren
hätte in der Form ja fast nicht
stattgefunden praktisch in letzter
Minute gelang eine Verständigung mit den
Angehörigen der Opfer mit Blick darauf
kann man es als großzügig bezeichnen
dass der israelische Präsident heute die
deutsche Erinnerungskultur ausdrücklich
lobte und mit dem Erinnern beginnt
Thomas reicherts Bericht
als Israel Staatspräsident izak Herzog
an diesem Nachmittag in das ehemalige
Konzentrationslager Bergen-Belsen kommt
will er eine Geschichte erzählen die
Geschichte seiner Familie bei der
Befreiung des Lagers im April 45 durch
britische Truppen war ein jüdischer
Offizier dabei er habe sich auf eine
Holzkiste gestellt erzählt Herzog und
dann auf jüdisch vor hunderten
menschliches Skelette gerufen
jeden Juden Juden gibt es hier noch
lebende Juden gibt es auf der Welt noch
lebende Juden
dieser jüdische Offizier war mein Vater
rein Herzog der spätere Staatspräsident
Israels
nun ist sein Sohn hier ebenfalls als
Staatspräsident an dem Ort des
Schreckens wo zehntausende getötet
wurden von deutschen unter anderem auch
Anne Frank
angesichts der Gräber der Toten von
Bergen-Belsen von Millionen ermordeter
der SOA ist jede Form von Antisemitismus
die es heute in Deutschland leider und
weiterhin gibt ein Alarmsignal für unser
Land
am Morgen ist Herzog im Bundestag in der
beginnt mit einem Gebet
bitte erheben sie sich sagt Israels
Staatspräsident
dieses corello gedenke Gott den Seelen
unserer Brüder und Schwestern des
jüdischen Volkes Haupt von der Schur der
sechs Millionen Seelen des jüdischen
Volkes
die getötet ermordet Herr drosselt
lebendig begraben wurden und der
heiligen Gemeinden die zerstört wurden
als Verpflichtung als moralische Aufgabe
und zitiert noch einmal seinen Vater
kein vergeben bringe ich und kein
Vergessen nur die Toten haben das Recht
zu vergeben die Lebenden haben kein
Recht auf vergessen
besonders nicht in Deutschland wo nach
Angaben des Innenministeriums
antisemitische Straftaten zuletzt und
knapp 29% zugenommen haben
Antisemitismus ist mitten unter uns in
der Mitte der Gesellschaft ihm in allen
Formen entschieden entgegenzutreten ist
unser aller Verpflichtung Herzog sieht
noch eine Verpflichtung den Schutz
Israels vor dem Iran und dessen Pläne zu
Entwicklung von Atomwaffen
Vernichtungswaffen in den Händen eines
UNO Mitgliedstaates der tagtäglich zur
Vernichtung eines anderen
unermitgliedstaates aufruft das ist
unannehmbar
der Applaus überdeckt in diesem Moment
dass es zur Eindämmung des Iran
unterschiedliche Ansichten gibt dass die
Lehren für die Gegenwart nicht immer die
gleichen sind
und jetzt nochmal Hans Wolf mit dem
Blick auf die Wirtschaft die
Papierindustrie warnt vor den Folgen der
gestiegenen Energie- und Rohstoffpreise
für die Branche die Geschäftsführer des
Branchenverbandes Gregor Geiger sagte
der dpa die gesamte Papierindustrie
stehe unter enormem Kostendruck weil er
realer was bedeutet das konkret ja der
Verband sagt dass es möglicherweise
sogar zu Engpässen kommen könnte das
erste prominente Opfer das gibt es schon
und das ist der
toilettenpapierhersteller hagle der hat
nämlich Insolvenz angemeldet für die
Branche sind die hohen Gaspreise eine
ganz große Belastung weil die
Herstellung von Papier sehr
energieintensiv Holz knapp und teuer ist
Hakle eine Traditionsfirma stellt seit
fast 100 Jahren Toilettenpapier hier die
Nachfrage ist nicht das Problem
Taschentücher Küchenpapier und Co werden
zurzeit wieder stark nachgefragt
inzwischen tun sich in den Regalen aber
schon wieder erste Lücken auf und nicht
nur bei Papierprodukten denn Angesicht
ständig steigender Preise werden die
Verhandlungen bei einer ganzen Reihe von
Waren mit dem Einzelhandel immer härter
die Hersteller bräuchten wegen
gestiegener Kosten eigentlich höhere
Preise die der Einzelhandel aber nicht
zahlt weil er seine Kunden nicht
vergraulen will es tobt ein regelrechter
Preiskampf zwischen Herstellern und
Handel aber auch andere Branchen könnten
wegen der gestiegenen Energiekosten bald
in Existenznot geraten
718 Insolvenzen gab es im August das
sind 26 Prozent mehr als vor einem Jahr
im Herbst kommen vermutlich noch einige
Insolvenzen hinzu von einer Pleitewelle
aber ist bislang nicht die Rede
vielen Dank
die Vereinigung Cockpit hat den ab
morgen angekündigten Pilotenstreik bei
der Lufthansa abgesagt nach dem heute
noch einmal verhandelt worden ist
Cockpit teilte mit man habe sich auf
eine Teillösung geeinigt Details sind
noch nicht bekannt
zwei ergebnisse vom Fußball in der
Champions League hat Borussia Dortmund
gegen den FC Kopenhagen drei zu null
gewonnen und die deutsche
Frauenfußball-Nationalmannschaft hat ihr
letztes
WM-Qualifikationsspiel gegen Bulgarien 8
zu 0 gewonnen
der Großbrand rund um den Brocken im
Harz hat sich unter der Erde weiter
ausgebreitet Wärmebilder hätten gezeigt
dass der Brand unterirdisch um 10 auf
160 Hektar gewachsen sei teilte das
Landratsamt Harz mit die Löscharbeiten
aus der Luft laufen daher unvermindert
weiter der Brand sei jedoch unter
Kontrolle das Feuer war am Samstag aus
bisher ungeklärter Ursache ausgebrochen
im corona-winter
2020/21 fieberten Millionen Deutsche mit
Boris Hermann mit 80 Tage lang segelte
er bei der wohndee Globe um die Welt
allein mit sich mit dem Boot und dem
Meer ein Abenteurer der an seine Grenzen
ging während wir hierzulande in der
Pandemie ja ziemlich begrenzt zu Hause
hockten im Südpolarmeer half Hermann
dann ein Schiffbrüchigen Konkurrenten zu
retten später rammte er selbst ein
Fischerboot also es wurde wirklich nie
langweilig mit ihm und so war wenigstens
einer von uns unterwegs aber natürlich
ist diese Form des Segelsports auch ein
Big Business bei dem es um Sponsoren
geht und welches hightech-boot man sich
leisten kann in Hamburg wurde heute
seine neue Yacht getauft jetzt kamen war
dabei
fällt die Flasche und bleibt trotzdem
Heil
ist das ein Land ein großes Glück bei
schiffstaufen so will es der Aberglaube
der Kommentare steht fort an Unheil ins
Haus Boris Hermann überspielt seinen
Schreck gekonnt ist doch die nagelneue
sea Explorer 3 gerade mal sieben Wochen
im Wasser und verspricht seitdem ein
Biest zu sein auf den Ozeanen dieser
Welt
der Rumpf ist runder das Cockpit ist
vorne mit Fenstern nach draußen komplett
überdacht das heißt wir waren jetzt auch
bei viel Wind komplett trocken innen
drin das ist manchmal ein bisschen
surreal richtig und dann die großen
Files die machen eigentlich den größten
Unterschied die machen das Schiffe
zusammen Dragster und das ist erst so
ein Biest was man erstmal lernen muss
auch zu bändigen werden dutzende Boote
begleiten den besten deutschen
Hochseesegler und sein neues Schiff
elbaufwärts darunter viele Schulkinder
die heute segelfrei bekamen zur Taufe
nahm der millionenschweren neubaukurs
auf die Heimatstadt des Skippers wieder
wird ein Traum Wirklichkeit
dieses ganze Projekt über vier Jahre mit
so einem tollen Team den Architekten und
allen Bootsbauern so ein aufregendes
Schiff zu bauen zur konzipieren das ist
natürlich ein großer neuer Lebenstraum
vorher hatte ich das Schiff ja schon im
fertigen Zustand übernommen in zwei
Jahren startet die nächste Globe das
härteste solo-rennen rund um die Welt
Anfang November schon geht's von der
Bretagne erstmal über den Atlantik nach
Guadeloupe
mehrere tausend Zuschauer in der
Hamburger Hafencity begrüßten den Mann
der seit etwa anderthalb Jahren sowas
wieder lieblingssegler der Deutschen ist
und dessen Erfolgsgeschichte jetzt
fortgeschrieben werden soll ja wir haben
jetzt ja versucht einen Schiff zu bauen
was besser durch den Southern Ocean
segeln kann was halt diesen anderen Burg
hat und runder ist und nicht ständig
abstoppt und mir auch mehr Komfort und
Platz in betet und
damit hoffe ich dass ich die Qualen ein
bisschen lindern kann und die Freuden
erhöhen im zweiten Versuch
hat es auch mit der Taufe geklappt der
erste war nur Probe und so muss
hoffentlich keiner irgendwelches Unheil
befürchten
das war es für uns gleich nach dem
Wetter geht es weiter mit der Reportage
Reihe 37 Grad heute mit dem Titel unser
Wunschkind und der Krieg über ein
deutsches Paar eine Leihmutter in der
Ukraine und die während des Krieges und
um 0:35 Uhr gibt es dann unsere
heute-update mit einer mit uns morgen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend tief peggy hat schon die
ersten Schauer und Gewitter zu uns
gebracht und jetzt wird die Warmfront
uns überqueren danach lockert das
vorübergehend auf und dann gibt es
morgen Nachmittag mit dieser Kaltfront
einige Regenschauer im Westen
Deutschlands schauen wir uns die
Gewitter der Nacht an die werden nämlich
wahrscheinlich so Richtung Niedersachsen
ziehen können und auch im Allgäu sind
schon die ersten shower unterwegs hier
im Südosten bildet sich dagegen Nebel im
Osten wird ja noch Ostwind da wird es
insgesamt auch kühler sein da sinken die
Temperaturen auf 14 bis 11 Grad der weil
es im Westen bei 17 bis 15 Grad milder
bleibt die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen so bei 2021 Grad an der Ostsee
wärmer wird es noch mal am Rhein mit bis
zu 27 Grad Regenschauer und Gewitter der
Nacht werden morgen über Tag weiter nach
Osten ziehen und das können dann lokal
auch Unwetter sein also Gewitter die mit
Starkregen verbunden sind hier im
Nordosten werden diese Gewitter wohl
morgen noch nicht ankommen und hinter
schauen und Gewitter lockern die Wolken
hier im schon wieder auf da geht es nur
die angesprochenen kleinen Regen shower
am Donnerstag werden Schauer und
Gewitter dann auch den Nordosten
erreichen auch Freitag und Samstag
bringen recht viel Regen das können so
in Summe 20 bis 60 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter werden bis zum Wochenende
und wenn sie auf noch mehr Regen hoffen
dann sehen Sie hier am Trend für Erfurt
die nächste Woche geht leider nur leicht
wechselhaft weiter guten Abend